it's time for me to flex on your kids
just a little bit don't worry I got this
new LG wallpaper TV it's seriously the
coolest TV I've ever have and I want to
show it off to you guys as you can see
perfect pictures perfect quality so it's
like looking through a window it
genuinely feels like it so as you can
see when it gets black it's actually
black which is a OLED technology that's
right Google it so cool you don't get
that in a lot of TVs also the way it's
so thin look how thin it is it's not
actually having a picture on your wallet
like I've never seen anything like it
it's so cool look at that how is that
even real so all the hardware is in the
sound bar which has amazing theater like
audio as well so it's got the perfect
theater video and audio experience with
Dolby vision and Dolby Atmos so it
really feels like a movie theater wait I
want to show this look at that it's a
window everybody
you're gonna need Windows anymore just
get an LG wallpaper TV I don't know how
to best describe it but it's genuinely
unlike anything I've seen Thank You LG
for sponsoring this video if you guys
want to check out one as well the link
is in the description and let's get back
to the video guys this is extremely
serious meems is about to get banned in
the EU this might be the last the Y we
have ever done and I'm going to savor it
- it's very little piece of meme welcome
to the final episode
[Music]
I know I know it's tough I know it's
tough but we must get through this
honestly I'm kind of glide I know why
everyone's like 50% of me says yes
there's a small part of me that uh
neuron eclis thinks you know what just
let him die just let him die you look at
memes like the Borah s skin 500 to 600
BC and you just have to think for
yourself just let it die let just burn
it all down let's just burn it all down
but anyway let's begin reviewing memes
if you understand this you're going to
hell damn it when you studied four years
of journalism and you end up writing for
BuzzFeed yeah who doesn't like to be
$25,000 in depth and took a career path
that can't really be adapted too much
Ellis what do you call a sad strawberry
a blueberry Jesus f man F outta here
listen you're being very rude
[Music]
it's too strong World War three will be
a battle royale it just makes sense but
is it going to be
Trump's take on battle royale is it
going to be a politically correct battle
Rhea a progressive thinking battle
royale hmm
sharing the memes I made with friends in
the ear so that I don't get in trouble
wouldn't it be awesome if memes just
becomes this underground illegal illegal
business I mean I guess it already is
and that's the point you know what we
live in the darkest most terrible time
line up vote if you want Gloria Borger
and poppy Harlow
to post pew news together now you're
just being greedy okay poppy would never
sing solo 8k all hell can be seen on
face Wow I look exactly like my dad it's
terrifying 4k can see sadness beyond
expression 720p looks pretty fine 360p
happier Scott Templin we need to reduce
the quality okay you can see my
depression and it's not pretty
moving on okay why do people if I needed
to take a break I would take a break
I appreciate the nice comments but no no
poor poppy poppy Harlow according to
Wikipedia is a Swedish under Swedish
news anchor best known for being the
anchor with the world's most reliable
few news Thank You Wikipedia for
delivering accurate information once
again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
fake its fake
okay it's not cringy if it's fake don't
waste my time with its 9 year olds I
miss fridays with pewdiepie me and
intellectual I miss pity by roasting
jacksepticeye in pretty much every video
damn it what happened well I guess he
died where girls cried where boys cried
where nine year olds cried oh that is so
sweet you're all a bunch of dummies
goodbye Gloria Borger and welcome poppy
Harlow with new unlocked characters
sleepy gets a comeback that's nice
that's pretty cool thank you
imagine a conversation between these two
people just give me another couple more
years on YouTube I'll end up like those
cuckoos PewDiePie is not actually
quitting he's just teasing the release
of PDP - dammit no no this is not true
meme correction there it is everyone why
don't you use the one where my skin hair
is brown why do you keep using that
picture name correction again do it
right
can we copy strike the Vikings really
we're still we're still doing this six
months later we get you gone to knuckle
memes fantastic you know maybe black
panther came out recently I would be
like oh that's funny Jesus Christ dude
bring back please don't tell my co
productions that would involve us
actually going outside and filming I
think not
6,800 people uploaded this that solely
takes guys literally anything can make
it on top of the loo i sub reddits Oh
check it out maybe yours yours will
definitely make it there as well
seeing Felix said he plans to delete his
channel in six months not knowing if
he's kidding or not I didn't even make
the joke
I already mean that I was gonna delete
my channel once like two years ago
remember that I wouldn't meme it twice
that would just be a douche do you know
you get one meme card of anything right
like juice on my channel you know I've
used all three meme cards but they've
expired I can never joke about it again
okay oh my god I saw this Logan can just
can't catch a break
xxx heartbreaking the world has been
stripped of a true great Soyoung so much
potential rest easy brother film it it's
a dead body wait I read the meme I saw
was different was like oh here it is
what's wrong pal shrink is a movie about
loving yourself for who you are
despite your physical appearance but
during the entire film they're making of
Lord Farquaad for being short oh my god
my mind has been blown this changes my
whole perspective on the world
I am now a depression as well me and my
younger brothers started a
breath-holding pull I read this already
can we copy strike marble why oh wow oh
no I can't unsee it now oh no oh this is
what's so great about the Internet is
that they they won't make fun of your
insecurities and
and your flowers really appreciate that
feeling bad about xxx and Jesse Owens
death making fun of EXO text enter dose
death oh no it's so sad what happened
click here for a chance to win a free
Big Mac and large drink Jesus Christ
this is a reason I didn't post anything
on Twitter when it happened cuz a lot of
it just seems like hey I found out this
person died and now I want to tell you
just telling rest in peace I remember
Whitney USand died so many people in my
feet were like rest in peace Whitney
Houston I'm like you don't give a [ __ ]
about Whitney Houston wait Whitney
Houston is dead did you know that
Whitney Houston's debut LP had four
number-one singles on it did you know
that Christie I freaking edited that on
Wikipedia and someone screenshot in it
and put it on reddit ain't got 1000 up I
never been so proud of you 9 year olds
I've never been so proud well done the
latest the subreddit like this was I
already addressed this and this was
after the Y came out start ever heard of
the immortal lost me yes do you think
it's overused yes Oh ever heard of them
or lost me no do you want to know what
it is no nor me alert yes wait how do
you win do you think it's overused no
are you good at finding lost memes yes
wait is this
[Music]
hey there it is again I don't I don't
know why these get so popular if
anything it makes me angry and why have
I worn headphones this entire episode
DreamWorks can we copy strike DreamWorks
can't wait copy strike I'm sure I'm sure
with the amount they they didn't claim
my Shrek video back huh no way it was
another one I don't remember which one
doesn't matter
DreamWorks I declared war stop stealing
my first persona or pounce
that's it for this week's Wow
you can also join in submit some memes
meet some new friends that's right
plenty of nine-year-olds for you to hang
out with finally check out the light
wise subreddit and your meme can make it
in next week of the ultimate glory of
nine-year-olds everybody goodbye man now
I don't like it this dude but I'll feast
no I don't know leave a comment